he is in his 13th year in the national
football league but is first with a new
team
outside of the city of detroit he is the
los
angeles rams quarterback matthew
stafford here on the rich eisen show how
are you matthew stafford
i am doing good rich how are you i am
doing well so uh
it took me when i moved uh to los
angeles back in 2003.
uh it took me a while to realize that
whenever i was working indoors this was
that nfl network
i was working indoors and it took me at
least
two three four weeks to stop lamenting
man i'm indoors when it's so beautiful
outside because it's usually very
beautiful outside have you gone through
that process
so far well luckily for me my job is
outside
um so i get to uh i get to enjoy it but
i am uh
i am enjoying it for sure that's uh i
pinch myself waking up and seeing the
sun up every day
about 70 75 degrees that's pretty nice
it sure is
so uh so far what have you been uh what
have you been doing so far to get
yourself acclimated football wise walk
me through that process
for you matthew yeah you know i think
i've just been trying to catch up as
much as i can
um you know i'm in a little bit of a
unique position in the fact that
everybody here has pretty much
been running some version of this
offense for the last four or five years
so
um you know they're definitely ahead of
the game when it comes to the mental
aspect when you know
as far as where i'm at so i'm just
trying to catch up do everything i can
there and then
last week we kind of started uh doing
some on-field stuff
i'm in a little bit of a limited
capacity but it was good to get out
there and meet the guys and
kind of start working with them throwing
with them and doing all that kind of
stuff so it's
it's picking back up but uh yeah it's
definitely a process for me and
something that
is a big challenge on the mental aspect
but i will uh you know do my part to
make sure i'm ready to go and what about
mcveigh he talks very fast
uh matthew he does he talks smart guy
he's got a lot to say
i know that um so i guess you have to
pick up his cadence as well
too i imagine yeah definitely there's
there's communication
um you know obviously he's he's given me
the place through the headset we're
talking constantly out of practice
um and you know and in the meetings and
all that kind of stuff just trying to uh
you know get to know each other as best
we can because that's a you know that's
an important relationship for
for not only uh the offense but our team
and so how many plays has he given you
or is he going to give you multiple ones
you're going to give you one and then
it's your job at the line to figure out
what what happens there i mean what is
the uh
the protocol that you're expecting oh
it's it's a little bit everything you
know sometimes we got one we got two
we got open-ended um you know just about
like everybody else in the nfl there's
uh
there's a bunch of different options but
uh you know it's it's definitely a
complex offense
one that uh you know has been you know
executing and uh been atop the nfl for a
long time around here so uh just got a
lot of uh
you know a lot of work to do to make
sure we keep it there and get better
let's get to the
the road to los angeles matthew stafford
um at what point did you
decide or figure out you your wife your
family your team
that um you were going to make an
attempt here
to start a new chapter football wise
can you walk me through that process
please matthew
yeah i mean that was a tough one um you
know it was something that uh
you know i definitely spent a lot of
time talking and thinking about with uh
you know people i'm close to mostly just
my wife um
you know and a little bit of family but
uh you know it was something that
kind of came to fruition after the
season and went in and talked to uh you
know the
uh the leadership over there in detroit
and and they were
amazing um you know to me they were
really receptive and understanding at
the same time
um you know we wanted to do what was
best for both both parties and i feel
like we got that done
um you know it was uh is about as smooth
the process as it can go when it comes
to
trading away somebody who's been you
know in your in your organization for 12
years
um so i was i was really appreciative of
the way they handled it and uh you know
i hope they were
um you know fond of the way i handled it
as well so it worked out um
you know i got nothing but great
memories there and and a bunch of great
friends and people i care a lot about so
it was tough to leave but at the same
time i'm excited for
you know a new chapter for me my family
and and um
you know out here in la is going to be a
lot of fun no question these things
could go sideways i mean you know that i
mean being in the league for over a
decade when you go into a front office
or
reach out to somebody who who did you
reach out to did you go to the owner
did you go to um whoever was the general
manager at the time
uh because you know there was such a
transition period i mean who did you
speak to with such a sensitive request
that if it gets
out it could send things in a totally
different direction than the one that it
it wound up in with you in los angeles
matthew
yeah i mean it was it was delicate no
question um you know and
and uh so i talked to to rodwood who's
our team president and
um sheila uh mrs fordham so that was uh
that those were the two people that i
talked to um you know and they were
obviously uh you know been been around
me for a while and understand where i
was coming from and
um you know i think disappointed but
also understanding and
you know responsive so that was uh that
was a good thing and and um
again i just can't say enough about the
way they handled it um
you know and i hope they feel the same
way you know with the way i did
um but just just happy that uh you know
you're seeing it today you know there's
there's all sorts of you know things
going on where uh
you know basically the player in the in
the team or the front franchise
you know aren't uh rtni to eye and i was
just happy that you know it worked out
as smoothly as it did for me
matthew stafford here on the rich eisen
show as for the why
to go uh and decide after 12 years you
know
i'm gonna take things a little bit in my
own hands even without you know having a
free agency
year that's right around the corner uh
to try and make a change
you spoke to the uh the great sam farmer
here in los angeles
for the la times i love that guy and you
spoke with him and i just want to
take an exchange from your your q a that
was printed in the los
angeles times last week he mentioned two
quarterbacks rich gannon and carson
palmer who were able to redefine
themselves in their last stops of their
career he asked you do you think about
that
your answer was there's no question
absolutely different scenario but even
tom brady last year going to a new team
at a different coaching new way of doing
things
and having success did brady in tampa
make you in a way sit down and go okay
if he can do that after 20 years and
after winning all those championships
there
maybe i can try did was he kind of in a
way uh
like a better phrase inspiration for you
to try
um i don't know you know i think i kind
of take in the landscape of the league
every year um obviously it was an
incredible thing that he was able to do
last year
um you know after basically knowing one
way for
a long long time and having a ton of
success and then just kind of picking up
and moving on and
and taking that success with him um
which i thought was really impressive
um some of those other guys that were
mentioned in that article obviously
um you know were part of it but at the
same time
uh just because one or all three of
those guys did what they did didn't mean
i was going to do what i was going to do
is
it was something that really came from
uh you know my family and
and my situation because everybody's
situation is different
but it is nice to know that um you know
it can't happen and guys have done it um
it's a lot of hard work and
you know a lot of a lot of changes and a
lot of new faces and all that kind of
stuff but uh you can you can definitely
make it work
matthew stafford here on the rich eisen
show and again uh to to say that you
know
you know we can say it in the business
that this is your most talented team
that you you've you've maybe been around
and
that's a lot to say certainly since
there's a first ballot hall of famer
that's going into megatron and you did
have some
talented players but i'm wondering what
your thoughts were when you were in this
huddle and seeing all these guys
cop and woods and cam acres and
whitworth as well the graybeard that's
going to have your back
i mean what was it like being in that
huddle looking around at your new
teammates
matthew um it was great you know
obviously
i've got a lot of respect for what a lot
of these guys have been able to do for a
long time in this league and
some of the you know immediate success
guys have had some young players that
are playing at a really high level so
uh more than anything you know i felt a
sense of responsibility to make sure
that i'm doing my part to make sure
these guys get to achieve everything
they want to achieve and
and uh you know at the end of the day
the quarterbacks you know the
facilitator
um i got to get these guys the ball and
and uh whether it's hand at the cam or
or uh you know throwing at the cooper
whatever it is um it's my job to make
sure that i'm getting them the ball so
they can do their thing and
and uh so i just felt a bunch of
responsibility to make sure that
as a new guy coming in that i was up to
speed and and uh doing everything i can
to try and uh you know immerse myself in
this offense and learn it and be there
as uh as quickly as possible
you are are you aware of the number of
uh times that you've had
a um a 100-yard rusher
either to your left what is it 10 or 12.
it's 11. right in the middle that's what
the difference it's 11 yeah 11 yeah it's
11 matthew
i mean um so what do you think of the
running core here and what it will add
to
what you can do because the general
sense of things is you are about to
be on a launching pad position in your
career in year 13. i wonder what you
think
right now um yeah i mean obviously
there's really talented players in the
backfield
um you know in this offense we do a
great job of mixing up looks and
and uh you know using motion to our
advantage
um you know i think we hand it to the
receivers we hand it to the running
backs uh you know um so it's it's gonna
be a
you know an exciting thing for me it's a
it's a lot to learn
lots of process to make sure i'm getting
us in the best plays and the best runs
um and then it's gonna be fun to watch
these guys up front um do their thing
and and the guys
carrying the ball you know go make guys
in the secondary miss and then break off
big runs so
i'm excited to be a part of it um you
know the whole culture of the whole
uh team everybody that i've met here has
been fantastic so i'm just
you know just excited about uh you know
trying to take take advantage of this
opportunity
okay in the few minutes i have left with
you matthew stafford what is the most
los angeles thing you've done
to date since being a los angeles
president what is literally the one
thing
i can't believe i'm doing yoga hot yoga
um
um what do you got avocado toast
what have you done i mean i i ate at
nobu and malibu i feel like that's
pretty trendy well done that deserves a
round of applause from the rich eyes and
show crew
um uh what you actually you know one of
the first
this is this is a los angeles thing you
know for for
some you know knock on wood um that uh
running into somebody in cabo is a very
los angeles thing
and it looks like that was the first los
angeles
thing you did right with sean mcvay yeah
we can we can check that off the list
yep i did that
um yeah i ran into it was a crazy crazy
thing ran into those guys down there him
and whit
and uh there were actually a bunch of
other nfl guys down there but uh
yeah i ran into those guys and and um
you know that was kind of
what jump started i think the whole
thing so it was uh
crazy seeing them down there and all
that but uh just glad that uh you know
worked out the way it did
so it was totally random that as you
were being potentially acquired by the
los
angeles rams that there was mcveigh
there was whitworth we
there was because again this is not free
agency it's not like the doubt the
the clippers running uh off to dallas to
keep deandre jordan or something like
that locked in their house like from a
couple of years ago
but maybe this was their maybe this was
planned
i don't know what do you think no it was
it was
it was honestly totally random um of all
the places to stay in cabo to be in the
same place
i was going down there just my wife uh
we didn't really know where we were
staying
um got a call on where we were going and
and uh
you know ended up being a very similar
or the same place that uh
uh you know whit and coach were at so it
was kind of a crazy
a crazy deal um you know and then it uh
you know kind of just snowballed from
there and um happened the way it did
well the other los angeles thing is to
to be on television have another human
being
offer you something for your parking
spot that's another los angeles thing
that happened on nfl network
a couple weeks ago it did some some
lunatic
some crazy guy was asking me for it but
uh you know you uh we could work
something out
because he figured out again you know
like i i already went to branded staley
of the chargers
and asked him for his spot on rams home
days
so if i get the chargers coach and the
rams quarterback
i think i'm walking like two feet to
work basically
do you know where your spot is you're
gonna be in a good spot do you do you
know where your spot is already
at so far stadium matthew or no you i
don't i have no idea i'm just
i'm just trying to figure out my
day-to-day at the moment whenever i
figure out where i'm parking i will uh
make sure i give you a buzz
look i know you're tight with clayton
kershaw but let me help you about los
angeles life as well
there's nothing more important than
parking there really isn't honestly
that's all we talk about is whose spot
is where and valley parking and where
you park did you really
walk did you really walk like walking
someplace
nobody does that here ever so i'm just
trying to help you with this i'm serious
i'm trying to help you with this uh and
then last one for you is it true kershaw
blew somebody up on a football field for
you
when you were kids is that really true
matthew stafford yeah that's true he got
ejected from a game
um you know he's my center and a guy hit
me late and then he
uh he took you know exception to that
and uh
hit it hit that dude even later and got
got booted from the game but i was all
for it
um and that's just uh that's just kind
of the competitor he is
you guys see it uh you guys have been
seeing it for years so just imagine that
guy
uh you know with some football pads on
and and
you can you could definitely imagine it
so wait a minute was he a late bloomer
was he how is he a center i mean was he
was he somebody who just yeah he
what he shot up in high school he got uh
you know
not that he was a small guy or a short
guy but he uh he definitely like
went from i don't even know five ten to
six three or whatever he is now
um in you know in a quick period of time
and
and uh that's when 97 came and he's
always had the curveball on the
all the you know competitive aspects of
being a great pitcher but uh
that extra heat came definitely when he
when he shot up so
if you were his catcher i mean you'd
prevent somebody from charging the mound
as well so because you guys go way back
he's done that for you absolutely okay
very good
matthew thanks for the time i saw you
wearing number nine too uh so i'll i'll
whatever whatever um you know you gave
welford if anything
uh uh you know i'll i'll i'll take half
that for the parking spot
and if certainly if it was nothing if he
just handed it to you i'll take your
spot
is essentially what i'm saying okay
perfect i'll keep that in mind can we
use the walford deal as
our as our benchmark stafford as a
framework
but i don't understand why i'm paying
you for you to have my spot i think it's
got to go the other way no i know that
that's what i'm saying whatever you
whatever you gave walford hopefully you
know unless
walford's just like here's my nine and
then you should just give me your spot
because again it was uh what it was a
bit more complicated than that so i'll
send you the numbers later is it a
spreadsheet
it's what are you talking about
i'm just kidding all right matthew
thanks for the time sir
always appreciate it welcome to los
angeles appreciate it rich have a good
one you better that's matthew stafford
the los
angeles rams quarterback here on the
rich eisen show hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here